buongiorno io credo di essere appunto un
anomalia nell'anomalia perché tutti gli
altri relatori stamattina viene invitata
ad allungare lo sguardo sul futuro
io invece devo invitarli a rivolgerlo
verso il passato tanto che onestamente
io mi sono anche chiesto se il mio
intervento sulla storia che volevo
raccontarvi oggi forse congruente con
l'impostazione con gli obiettivi con le
finalità di questa iniziativa e ho avuto
questo dubbio fino a stamattina
devo dire che lo aveva ascoltato le
persone che mi hanno preceduto
ho capito che invece no si incastra
abbastanza bene in quello che avete
detto e in quello che ancora verrà verrà
detto io parlerò di un elemento che
viene dal passato tra l'altro vedete chi
fa il mio mestiere per chi si inoltre la
foresta dei fatti storici finisce spesso
per imbattersi in personaggi donne o
uomini che siano di cui si è smarrita la
memoria ma sono persone alle quali
abbiamo spesso chiesto magari non noi ma
i nostri padri ei nostri nonni e quindi
in un certo senso anche noi se ci
pensate di spendere la loro vita per a
vantaggio della nostra e poi li abbiamo
però tranquillamente rossi ecco se io vi
chiedessi adesso quale ricordo ero cra
in voi il nome alfonso giordano molti
rimarrebbero perplessi
qualcuno dei più anziani forse
assocerebbe questo nome a quello del
presidente di un famoso processo di
mafia degli aiutanti credo che nessuno
però
si ricorderebbe di un altro alfonso
giordano c'era un piccolo medico di un
centro non lontano da palermo che la
lercara friddi allora centro minerario
produttore di zolfo il padre galfond
sarà medico e quindi come spesso
accadeva nella società di allora
alfonso diventa mentito ma vedete essere
medico alves cara freddi in quel periodo
alfonso visse tra la metà dell'ottocento
i primi anni del novecento nacque nel
1843 morirà nel migliore 115 era un
compito estremamente gravoso
estremamente gravoso perché il paese che
erano sempre un piccolo centro agricolo
essendo state scoperte nel sottosuolo
ricchi fa scoperti ricchi giacimenti i
filoni di zolfo lo so se la loro del
diavolo ricorda qualcuno era diventato
un aree industrializzate un'area per la
verità selvaggiamente industrializzata
dai gestori delle miniere tanto che non
soltanto la salute degli abitanti alla
messa a rischio dalle emissioni di
anidride solforosa che si spandevano
nell'aria ma perfino la loro incolumità
perché lo scavo delle gallerie provocava
frequentemente i crolli delle abitazioni
eppure a lercara tutti facevo
eliminatori anche le donne tanto il
ragazzino ai bambini di 12 anni 11 anni
dieci anni e molti di essi si ammalavano
tutti dalla stessa malattia
tutti questi sintomi tutti dallo stesso
malanno era un malanno che si chiamava
anch'io sto miasi
che un nome elegante come sentite no
sinuoso quasi sensuale elegante colto di
un male però di un male feroce di una
sorta di aree mia che colpiva i
lavoratori delle miniere e soltanto essi
e nessuno ne capiva da da giovane
alfonso giordano che studiava
attentamente i pazienti ma anche il modo
e il mondo in cui vivevano riuscì
finalmente a rendersene conto
ed era una causa molto semplice per il
fatto che i minatori consumavano i loro
pasti all'interno delle gallerie con le
mani coperte dalla polvere di zolfo dal
sudore che gli colava addosso perché le
gallery la temperatura sopra i 40 gradi
ecco allora questa era la causa ma non
era da parte di quella povera gente non
curanza era una cosa molto più semplice
era che nel energia e delle miniere
l'acqua non c'era non c'è l'acqua da
bere bisogna comprare l'acqua da bere e
provate a immaginare se fosse possibile
comprare l'acqua per lavarsi le mani era
assolutamente inimmaginabile che una
cosa del genere potesse accadere e
dunque non rimaneva altra alternativa se
non nutrirsi con le mani sporche e
giordano scoprì appunto che per quella
via per quelle mani un parassita passava
dalle viscere della terra in quelle del
popolo delle miniere e cominciò la
ricerca per risolvere quel problema
ricerca che devo dire in tempi
abbastanza rapidi diede dei buoni
risultati ma si impegnò anche perché
fosse istituito un servizio sanitario
per gli zolfo tar
un servizio che non si era mai pensato
di creare non sta neanche mai immaginato
di creare e perché le condizioni di quei
disgraziati fossero rese un po più
vivibili di quanto non erano state fino
a prometto riuscì perfino a curare
individuare un'altra malattia anch'essa
col nome molto elegante si chiama
teatrino curiosi che era un affezione
delle vie respiratorie veniva dall
inalazione del pulviscolo solforoso e
soprattutto avviò una grande battaglia
culturale per l'eliminazione di
un'antica piaga quella di utilizzare di
adibire i bambini quelle di 12 11 10
anni al trasporto fuori dalle case del
minerale scavate lo si faceva da sempre
e i carichi dei bambini spurs sono tali
da provocare deformazioni dello
scheletro perché almeno 10 anni portava
un peso di 30 kg che era quasi del suo
periodo al peso suo effettivo giordano
insomma ma fu un professionista che
impegnandosi quotidianamente nel suo
lavoro
riuscì a rendere più accettabile la vita
di molti altri e dunque nel mondo
contemporaneo è stato ea ovviamente
dimenticato ma anche se questo oblio lo
avesse previsto
non credo se ne sarebbe molto
preoccupato perché i veda in quella
condizione che mi riceva nasini definiva
la felicità per quello che faceva
è dunque quello che contava per lui era
appunto arrivare al traguardo
raggiungere il risultato è questo valeva
per lui
io mi auguro e auguro valga anche per
tutti coloro che operando nei campi più
diversi anche apparentemente banali
quotidiani
la condividono però l'esigenza di
operare così come accadeva un tempo
nell'interesse e per il bene collettivo
e alla mia storia si chiude a questo
punto
[Applauso]